madden nfl 23 is live for all players
and there are a bunch of new and
returning madden players alike now is a
perfect time to talk tips you definitely
want to know so you can crush your
friends roommates and siblings alike on
the gridiron let's get started
now i was really caught off guard by
skill based passing because you know
usually madden feels like a copy of the
previous year but with a little touch up
of paint skill-based passing however
fundamentally alters the dynamic of your
offense and it's been a pleasant
surprise to see
basically the idea is with skill-based
passing you have a tighter control of
ball placement which is really clutch
when it comes to specific scenarios like
leading your receiver throwing in a
tight window low and away from the
cornerback or if you have a size
mismatch like kyle pitts or travis
kelsey tossing one high and out of reach
from the defender
there are three options in handling
skill based passing one is by using the
precision passing meter which handles
the accuracy of your pass the other and
it's my preferred choice has the meter
simply dictate your throw power holding
down the button slings out a bullet pass
and anything less is basically
considered a touch pass i've made throws
in the past madden games that would be
considered a lob but they were actually
touch passes in madden 23 which shows
that the range of the touch pass is
significant
however i know some of you guys
particularly older madden players you
might not like this change and that's
okay there's an option to simplify by
using the classic gameplay when it comes
to passing
madden lets you mess with the camera
angles on both sides of the ball if you
find that the default angle isn't quite
what you're looking for just press the
d-pad to mess with it and you can have a
starting point closer to your qb or
further away giving you an eagle-eye
view of most of the field i tend to mess
with this more on offense but on the
defensive side of the ball you can even
flip the camera over to change
perspectives and hone in on a defensive
player it can take a little bit of
adjusting but also offers you
potentially more control
[Applause]
your instinct may be to sprint whenever
you have the ball in your hands but it
is not always the best idea sprinting
negatively affects your ability to make
cuts or perform other moves at their
fullest such as jukes and spins instead
of constantly holding down r2 or the
right trigger use it in the open field
or right after you make a cut through
the hole as a running back or a kick
returner it will help you get defenders
out of position as you turn on the
afterburners and leave them whiffing on
a tackle sometimes your ball carrier may
get stood up on a tackle and you'll be
prompted to match the a button or x if
you're on playstation to get out of it
you should know that this is optional
and while doing so might wiggle you free
to keep running it also puts you at
greater risk of fumbling the ball this
will more rarely happen against the cpu
but if you're playing a human opponent
you may be best to settle for the yards
you got and not try to break out for
more to give up on the play in the
middle of the qte you can press x or
square on playstation to go to the
ground and prevent disaster
in madden usering relates to the
defender that you decide to play as you
can change this at any point even mid
play but you should pick a position you
can play with skill for example if you
find yourself late to react to crossing
routes and double moves you shouldn't be
playing corner or else you'll become a
liability to your team the safest
position in most cases for those who
feel they have a lot to learn on defense
is the defensive tackle position on the
line as your job will usually just be to
plug up the inside running lanes leaving
the cpu to handle coverage pass rush and
spying the qb
[Applause]
calling chunk plays is as good in real
life as it is in madden you've got to
establish the run to set up the pass if
you can successfully break off two or
three runs early from the same formation
or even with the same play coming out in
the same formation later could get your
opponent guessing wrong that you're
about to run it again this makes for the
perfect time to set up the play action
pass from the same formation it'll look
exactly like what they're expecting
right up until the moment that they've
bid on the play fake and you pulled out
the rug under them now you're bombing
the ball over their heads to your wide
out on a deep post
trust me it looks as good as it feels
too
[Music]
uh yeah i usually avoid talking about
ultimate team but understanding ultimate
team and whether or not it is right for
you is important you know the people who
love this mode they've already sunk in
100 bucks and they have their mutt team
at about the mid 80s right now in
overall ranking other players completely
disregard mutt and they want nothing to
do with it usually for you guys that
watch my madden videos and for those of
you watching this right now you tend to
be the latter group and i understand
that completely so feel free to talk to
me in the comments and let me know what
you'd like to see change in ultimate
team in the future but for those of you
curious let's break it down ultimate
team in short is basically a mode where
you get to build your own team from
every nfl player by starting off with
the crappy ragtag team and taking on
challenges of increasing difficulty you
get players through packs think of it
like collecting trading cards and you
can then pop your cards in and out of
your lineup in different ways crafting a
team with your game style you can trade
these cards sell them for different
kinds of currency and you can use your
lineup to take on different missions and
challenges successfully beating
challenges will earn you xp stars and
sometimes specific cards when you feel
comfortable enough with your team
strengths you can hop in online and
challenge other ultimate teams also be
sure to take on each challenge one at a
time and if you're up to it start at the
highest difficulty possible which
usually isn't bad in the first few
minutes and the set of challenges
make sure to always aim for the optional
objective as well as that will give you
maximum stars upon completion letting
you get better rewards
field passes are completely new to
madden but may be familiar to anyone who
has seen the free tracks on certain
battle passes like in fortnite destiny 2
or even warzone it's a nice addition in
madden 23's live service model giving
players that don't want to shell out
cash and ultimate team a decent option
to grind for xp and in return get a
smattering of coins and occasionally
packs or even solid standout players
there are different kinds of field
passes so be sure to check the timer and
get some xp in on the ones that might
end soon
madden 23 isn't for everyone but it's
worth a look particularly if you haven't
played madden in a few years you might
be pleasantly surprised by some of the
changes to the core gameplay
let me know if you're playing madden 23
and what guides you would like to see
next if you plan on skipping madden this
year sound off in the comments
be sure to tell me what it would take
for mata to earn your height back for
you to hop back onto the field now keep
an eye out for our official review
coming out early next week as well and
go raiders
[Music]
you